[Musica]
dopo tutti questi horror che sono usciti
i giorni mi serviva un gioco tranquillo
grazie a dio sono aggiunti ragazzi
pervenuti a questo video sono vari
generi da oggi siamo tornati su rake che
è un gioco tranquillo appunto me l'avete
chiesto tutti tutti quanti di rifarlo
non volevo rifarlo perché lo conoscesse
ragazzi ray che un video game nel quale
bisogna trovare il ray questo ragazzo il
mio fucile che non serve un cazzo non
serve ben 30 mente un cazzo perché il re
che più forte non ha prima cosa ragazzi
devono piazzare telecamere che le
telecamere per riprendere il rake perché
allora rake sarebbe questa figura strana
per non dire una merda siccome ci sono
sti bellissimi al ciao zio ciao come
stai
no non scappare non ti voglio solo
inglobare ascoltami state se c'è la mira
ho preso lui ma non c'entrava la minchia
povero cristo e la madonna quante case
ci sono mio dio è bella
magari vernice re in attimino se avete
voglia e per carità è un loft lo
mettiamo su ebay lo vendiamo di
videocamere anche qua e là ci siamo come
potete vedere ragazzi il nostro bouake
molto simpatico e siccome gli piace
giocare
giochiamo prendiamo questo sniper
torniamo alla base ci siamo tutto a
posto
facciamo arrivare la notte all è sempre
avanti
sono carico non sento sarà dura e
ragazzi ve lo dico non riuscirò mai ad
uccidono ma riuscirò ad ucciderlo
stavolta lo giuro prima di uscire i
ragazzi fatevi dare un'occhiata alla
veloce giusto per vedere se trovo alla
madonna ti sei voluto vedo una luce lì è
normale che ci sia una luce cos'è ho ho
ho trovato per bastardo non ci rinunci
gare ma come
[Musica]
fate no no quelle mia quella è mia ma
[ __ ] lurido pezzo di schifo ho perso
una camera vaffan cuore dobbiamo uscire
che devo farlo fuori mi ha scassato la
camera ci siamo l'ex spice non sei tu
eccola abbiamo trovato il cinghiale
morto
ci siamo paci tipo bergreen stragà si
trovò le tracce arriva all 81 ammazzo ti
denuncio ti denuncio t'ammazza una delle
due dov'è no dovete dov'è andato via
stronzo allontaniamoci di qua rega
finisce male non lo so nostro cinghiale
via via via via via via velocissimo
ricorrere come se non ci fosse un domani
bye bye bye bye bye bye sea hawk calmo
saic ha allora qua sopra che non credo
che riesca ad arrivarci che ha visti
delle mine antiuomo o anti rake del
cazzo come si chiama vi basterebbe
piazzarne una pa dietro e potrei tipo
cecchinare tutta la notte finché non
spuntava rispetto all'altra volta
abbiamo fatto già troppo cioè non è mai
successo così tanto tiro che ti prendo
gli arti triste ecco prendi il cecchino
ama ca so santi i frullatori
nell'inventario se un po più di rosa
magari ma dai ma dov'è andato al centro
commerciale che cazzo era andato a da
zara ragazzi e da zara è lì che fa
shopping dove è andato cosa vai a fare
nella foresta di tutti ma [ __ ]
vari di morire tu e tua sorella maya va
anche lei sono sopra sono sopra il
cinghiale fatti vedere
mostrati gli at invoco satana
con questo porco in sacrificio dai borga
[ __ ] o ex nolo manca tissimo se n'è
accorto mi dicono sì che accorre più
veloci di usain bolt ditte che si è
incazzato ammazzato il cinghiale ai
sugli alberi stai questa cosa non
l'avevo messa in conto effettivamente
bravo che sa di scalare gli alberi
complimenti sei voglia di far bene
cadere una donna ciao mi ha teso una
trappola nebbia e ha pure funzionato tra
l'altro non mi ricordavo che l'onda
energetica di goku facesse parte di
questo videogame scusate mi regala frega
e l'onda di goku e lei è sì salve ho
trovato una sfera del drago mi scusi io
posso toccare il pube non erano ero ero
tranquillo e ce l'ho detto in modo
pacifico
non te la sei mica presa sul personale
vero zio la testa piuttosto spararle ma
andiamo alle sparo da perte di riserve
morgan
cioè ho appena ucciso una che cazzo sei
gergo di satana ma chi
o porca eva che cazzo avete fatto al mio
camper l'autolavaggio lo paga lui escono
ma non è che vado io a scrostare sta
minkia come cazzo ha fatto a mettere un
cinghiale sul mio camper
cosa hai visto spiega che cosa hai visto
di quello che è successo di melo
nessuno ha visto niente qui iphone
quanti soldi che ha corrotto spiega te
lo meriti e stai anche zitto non è che
sta qua the unknown o no è piccola ma
sono assicuro qua dentro
mi sento immortale tu non puoi nulla
contro il potere della casetta di legno
poi sono dentro casa come ha fatto come
ha fatto che sono dentro queste mura
d'acciaio li ammazzo le famiglie che
cos'è mamma sei tu questo buffo sesto
rumore bruttissimo ci togliamo dalle
palle grazie non volentieri come lo
zucca come los tutti spiega melo se non
lo vogliono in dettaglio proprio 6
voglia di venire a trovarmi in app di
melo che organizziamo la cena di natale
cucino il cinghiale hai sbagliato
avete presente quando da piccoli vic
aggravate addosso trovate il pannolino
ecco qui adesso uguale solo che non
c'era il pannolino purtroppo na roba in
che cosa mi chi è o mio dio no ma stai
calmo c'è se lo dice vita andava a
comprare al supermercato un po di cervo
3 dai 8 preso ma se ti ho preso in bocca
da un chilometro cosa vuoi dovrò correre
al caravan perché sono praticamente
veramente sono morto se mi tocca
un'altra volta sono veramente morto
piano di evacuazione d'emergenza ragazzi
via piano bene non ci veloci veloci
veloce veloce sono vivo già fatta allora
santo dio
chiudi che sudata ragazzi ma dai ragazzi
è passata la notte ringraziando iddio
non ce la posso più fare è tragico
e veramente tragica tra l'altro ragazzi
sto registrando così cioè mila non si
vede un cazzo casa mia è totalmente buia
tranne questa lucina qua infatti non si
vede un pene quindi ragazzi
abbiate pietà comunque ragazzi servito
era piaciuto ma sta certamente è un mi
piace se resti di scatti ci vediamo in
questo video